[Music]
hey guys Helen here wisecracks resident
science nerd
while 14 year old Jared was waiting in
line seven hours early for the Matrix
Reloaded
I was playing with my Star Wars action
figures acting out weird love triangles
between qui-gon Jango and Princess Leia
and trying to convince my family that my
home planet was actually Alderaan so I
decided to flex my Star Wars geekery for
this discussion of Disney's latest
installment in the Star Wars Cinematic
Universe solo the movie fills in the
backstory of our favorite smuggler
turned hero showing us how a young Han
transforms into the legendary Han Solo
sort of given that the other films have
been massive cash cows Solo was expected
to do pretty well even considering the
last Jedi backlash and potential
franchise fatigue but solo flopped it's
on track to be the first unprofitable
Star Wars film ever
this should surprise you for one reason
everything about this movie is designed
to be marketable and give you the warm
fuzzies so what went wrong let's take a
look in this wise track edition on how
even psychology couldn't sell solo
thanks to our sponsor brilliant org for
making this video possible
and as always spoilers away solo kicks
off sometime around the year 13 BBY
that's 3264 on the waffle calendar and
ends roughly ten years before rogue 1
and a new hope the movie follows
aspiring pilot and scoundrel to be Han
as he goes from a bright-eyed romantic
to an outlaw who shoots first
all right mess along the way he picks up
a lovable 190 year-old Wookiee a
notorious techno sexual smuggler and the
Millennium Falcon though he doesn't
quite pull off the Kessel run in less
than 12 parsecs unless you round down
here's solos fundamental strategy make
us nostalgic for the good old days of
Star Wars by cramming in as many Easter
eggs and nods to the Past our Wars as
possible there's the golden dice the
planet Felucia fight for droids
Mandalorian armor Twi'leks Jabba the
Hutt boss the Bounty Hunter Cole of
office and of course Darth Maul and
that's just scratching the surface the
movie is one easter egg after the next
pulling references not only from the
films but also from the novelizations
the video games and the animated series
the reference to Aurra sing
Lando's the skies from attorney the Jedi
and Kira's impressive command of teras
kasi are great ways to make fans whom no
two generations worth of Star Wars lore
feel like they have a special connection
to the film but despite the outstanding
fanservice and some great deep cuts the
movie falls short because nostalgia
alone can't propel a film and might even
get in the way well I can't read
Disney's mind the reason they relied on
all this nostalgia seems pretty obvious
marketers use nostalgia to sell stuff
all the time and it's no different in
movies just look at the force awakens
besides bringing back the actual
characters and actors from the original
trilogy the film paid homage to its
predecessors in the form of things like
trash compactors podracing flags and
even that werewolf alien thing from the
moss eisely Cantina neuroscience has a
possible explanation for why this trick
could be super effective it involves the
brain's reward system some imaging
studies have shown that the parts of the
brain tied to feelings like pleasure
motivation and euphoria are activated
when you're experiencing a stall jet so
for longtime Star Wars fans seeing
things like Hans dice and hearing the
sound of the Imperial fighters are like
a jump to hyperspace for the feel-good
pathways in your brain which is exactly
what Disney wants to happen because then
you'll keep coming back for more or buy
some solo dice cufflinks in a castle run
t-shirt but nostalgia marketing aside
these Easter eggs do something else in
the case of humor being on the receiving
end of an inside joke makes us feel more
affiliation with the jokester and makes
them seem more socially desirable
do not understand I do I understood that
reference and according to the
encryption theory of humor jokes are
funny not just because of their
superficial content but because they
broadcast shared knowledge between the
funny person and their audience so if
you caught yourself laughing in the
scene where Chu is losing it over being
beaten that to Jarek or the one where
he's holding up the guards severed arms
the writers did their job from a
psychology standpoint the fact that
Disney shares your inside knowledge that
wikis rip people's arms off makes you
feel like they get it but Sir nobody
worries about upsetting a droid that's
cause a droid don't pull people's arms
out of their sockets when they lose
these are known to do that but here's
where solo lands itself in trouble
plenty of movies have inside jokes and
references while also giving us
well-developed characters but in the
process of doubling down on the stall
check Easter eggs Disney fails to give
us a legit origin story solos
fundamental problem is that Alden
Ehrenreich has to convince us he's
Harrison Ford's Han Solo from the very
start
he's got the arrogance the wisecracks
the hustle Han suppose a transition is
basically 75% complete right from the
beginning so by the time he shoots
Beckett at the end it doesn't seem like
much of a change
he's been acting like Harrison Ford the
whole time the film makes gestures of a
transformation but they seem
half-hearted when crammed between 8,000
other nostalgia triggers as a result for
a film that promises to showcase the
development of one of the most beloved
characters in sci-fi history it feels
more like a BuzzFeed top 10 list of Han
Solo trivia even significant plot points
like the way Han gets his last name
meets Lando or wins the Millennium
Falcon feel like Easter eggs take Hans
relationship with Chewie
Hans only known him for a couple of
minutes before the relationship has the
same dynamic as it does throughout the
rest of the saga normally we'd expect
this kind of connection to develop and
mature over time but because Disney's
top priority was to trigger nostalgia
and familiarity rather than the truly
show development it ends up feeling
shallow the movie gets it out of the way
and moves on to the next bit of trivia
the point of an origin story is to show
us how a character we know and love
comes to be who the
our for instance Batman Begins shows
Bruce Wayne mastering his fears to
become the legendary Dark Knight Bruce
starts out as a troubled angsty scared
youth at the beginning and by the end
he's disciplined and unafraid dr.
strange starts off as a self-centered
surgeon who only believes in cold
rationality and ends the film as a self
sacrificial mystic but to be honest I
kind of get it when you're recasting
such an iconic role you get stuck
between a rock and a hard place if Hans
antics at the beginning seems completely
different than Harrison Ford the
audience wouldn't believe they were
watching Han Solo but if you have him
act like Ford Solo from the beginning
you sacrifice a convincing arc for
familiarity if we were to try to give
the film more credit we might say that
the arc is Han going from an aspiring
scoundrel to an idealist when he decides
to hand over the hyper fuel to the
budding resistance but isn't that the
exact same art from a new hope at worst
the film has network and at best it's a
retread of Episode four that's not to
say solo doesn't have moments of fun but
that's really the best thing you could
say about it and hey if that's what
you're looking for it's a good time but
in our opinion Disney could have done
better by delivering an intriguing
character we rather than relying on
cheap appeals to nostalgia in the form
of endless Easter eggs but that's our
take leave us yours in the comments
below on the other hand if you'd rather
work hard for your dopamine hits see if
you can solve this riddle if I were to
tell you that the combined area of the
blue triangles is twenty five and the
five red squares are identical what is
the area of the entire shape pull out
some scrap paper if you need it this
brain teaser comes from brilliant org
the site that helps you deeply
understand math and science perfect for
numbers people regular people and Mon
Calamari alike if you're into
neuroscience like I am they've got a
great module on artificial neural
networks which are like real neural
networks but artificial they've also got
an awesome section on engineering which
is something that kind of makes me want
to go back to school one more time to
become an engineer to check out
brilliant head to brilliant org slash
wisecrack and sign up for free the first
200 people to click the link will also
get 20% off the annual premium
subscription by clicking the link you
can also
access to the solution so what should we
look at the science of next drop me a
line in the comments till next time
Helen out and may the force be with you
[Music]
you